becoming the queen of arendelle probably
never crossed your mind Anna but it
probably crossed else's mind more than a
few times your sister has a lot on her
plate and she's got secret memories that
are bound to surface and frozen too it
also finds her tribe she might want to
be relieved of her duties as Queen
Regina Christophe agreed to become the
king and queen of arendelle
were dying to know don't get us wrong
Elsa is a fantastic Queen but what if
she wants to be more than that would
honored give her her freedom by taking
over the throne
well that sounds like something the
selfless Anna would do watch until the
end to find out why Anna will become the
queen of arendelle and frozen - Elsa
managed to let things go and embrace her
true self and frozen but it looks like
something is terribly wrong with Elson
frozen to the d23 Walt Disney Studios
panel brought some new information to
light and we now know that something is
up with the queen of arendelle Elsa is
hearing voices and terrified of messing
things up again she gets comforted by
Anna but feels compelled to follow the
voice despite being scared of where
it'll bring her Elsa spent her entire
life feeling like the odd went out her
father taught her to conceal her
feelings and control her powers but that
wasn't the best advice after
accidentally outing herself at her
coronation Elsa ran away and tasted
freedom for the very first time since
then she's moved back to arendelle and
resumed her duties as Queen but
something tells us that Elsa wants more
out of her life and the truth would be
nice for starters
past is not what it seems we know for a
fact that else is going on an adventure
come frozen to grand pabbie made it
clear that else's past is not what it
seems and she seems determined to find
out the truth but what if the truth
changes everything whether it does or
not it's safe to assume that things are
drastically going to change after the
sequel it's been confirmed that
Christophe is going to attempt to
propose to Anna throughout the film Anna
and Kristoff will go on to have a family
and maybe even move out of the castle
people love a royal wedding but Elsa
isn't thinking about tying the knot
anytime soon she's on a quest to find
herself but is that really what
arendelle needs right now we're all for
a single queen but she'll need to pass
the throne down at some point or another
if Elsa isn't interested in raising a
family of her own she might choose to
ditch her title and pass it down to Anna
and Kristoff so this is what a party
looks like Elsa was born first which
puts her first in line for the throne
but just because you're supposed to do
something doesn't mean you have to Elsa
is a wonderful Queen but her title stops
her from traveling the world and with
powers like hers she could literally
venture into the unknown Anna is brave
loyal selfless and best of all she loves
social events and parties it's
coronation day
all in all on AHA's everything arendelle
is looking for in a queen and Kristoff
would make a fabulous king - if there's
one question that's plagued us from the
start it's why Elsa has powers but Anna
doesn't something just doesn't add up
and fans all over the world are curious
to find out the answer according to
chief creative officer Jennifer Lee this
sequel will explain how Elsa got her
powers finding out the truth might make
Elsa feel like she's been living a lie
Jennifer even went on to say that in the
end nothing will be the same but what
does that mean exactly see you in two
weeks do you have to go you'll be fine
Elsa Anna and Elsa are going to find out
a lot about their parents and
grandparents in frozen to general
Matthias is going to fill the sisters in
after crossing paths with them in the
intented forest Elsa might find out that
there are others like her it's a popular
theory that the elements we see in the
frozen to trailer have more meaning than
we think fans are convinced that each
element belongs to someone with magical
powers so what if Elsa finds out that
she's not alone that there are others
like her out there would she really
choose to go back to her old life in
arendelle
we have our doubts there's no way of
knowing what Elsa and Anna will find
once they pass through the enchanted
lands but what it also finds out that
she's not meant to rule arendelle she's
meant to be the ice queen
finding her tribe and finally feeling
like she belongs could change the way
she feels about going home we think it's
possible that Elsa won't want to go back
home at the end of frozen to she might
ask Anna to take over her duties as
Queen and find the courage to let her go
this would truly be a heartbreaking
scene after all Elsa and Anna had been
together since the very beginning but it
wouldn't be goodbye forever Elsa would
totally be Ana's maid of honor at her
wedding and she would never miss a
birthday or holiday with powers like
Elsa's we're sure the sisters would find
a way to keep in touch things are going
to change the end of frozen - and we
think Anna and Kristoff are going to
become at the queen and king of
arendelle what do you guys think will
happen at the end of frozen - tell us in
the comments why Elsa doesn't want to be
the queen of arendelle and that's a wrap
hit that subscribe button give this
video a like and don't forget to comment
thank you for watching the things we'll
see you soon
[Music]